DR. PETER DOURMASHKIN:
I would like
to now analyze the motion
of a system of particles
that has both translational
and rotational motion.
So I'm going to
consider a pulley,
and the pulley has
radius R. And there
is a string wrapped around THE
pulley and a block of object 1
that's on a plane, and
another block of object 2.
And as object 2 falls
down, the pulley
rotates and object 1
moves to the right.
And there's a coefficient
of friction between block
1 and the surface.
Now, in order to analyze this
problem, I'm going to apply,
for the pulley, our
torque equals I cm alpha,
and for each of the
blocks, I'll apply
F1 equals m1 a1 and
F2 equals m2 a2.
But the important
thing to realize
is that these three
quantities, the acceleration
of block 1, the
acceleration of block 2,
and the angular
acceleration of the pulley,
are constrained because
this string is not
slipping around the pulley.
And so let's begin to
analyze this type of problem.
So we'll start with
the torque principle.
Now, what's crucial in
all of these problems
is that we're relating
two different quantities,
vectors on both sides.
The physics quantities
have definite direction,
and our alpha a1
and a2 as vectors
are determined by our
choice of coordinates.
So what I'd like to do is
draw a coordinate system,
a rotational coordinate system.
Now, the way I'll do it is
I'll draw an angle theta.
And now I have to draw
a right-hand move,
so my angle theta will
look as though it's going
into the plane of the figure.
And so I write cross
n hat right-hand move,
and I'm going to just to
define that to be k hat.
Now, what that allows me to
do, when I write my point
s here will be cm.
So I'm going to calculate
this about the center of mass,
and I get I cm alpha.
As soon as I draw the
coordinate system, then
this side becomes the
vector alpha z k hat,
where alpha z is the z component
of the angular acceleration.
And technically, the
reason this angle
is there is because this
is the second derivative
of that angle.
And that's well-defined now.
So the next step is
to define the force,
to do what we call
a torque diagram.
So this is my rotational
coordinate system.
The next step is to
construct a torque diagram,
and the way we do that
is we draw the object.
We indicate our rotational
coordinate system.
I don't have to put
the theta anymore.
Now, here's a subtle point.
I'm going to draw
the rope that is
connected to the pulley
as part of my system.
This is the part where
the tension here, I'll
call that T2, and over here,
this is the tension T1.
Now, on the pulley, there
is a gravitational force,
and there's some pivot
force on this pulley.
And now what I want to consider
is the torque about the Cm.
Now, the pivot force, f pivot,
and the gravitational force,
produce no torque
about the pivot,
so I'm just going to eliminate
those for the moment,
and just focus on the
torque due to T1 and T2.
So I draw my vector Rs
T1 and my vector Rs T2.
So this is what a torque
diagram consists of.
Let's summarize it.
It's our system,
the relevant forces
that are producing torque,
vectors from the point we're
calculating the torque.
Our S is the center of mass.
And the vector from where
we're calculating the torque
to where the force is acting.
And now, when we calculate
the cross-product of Rs and T,
we put these two
vectors tail to tail,
and notice that this
vector is giving us
a torque out of the board,
our positive direction
is into the board,
so over here we
have minus T1 R.
Whereas T2, when
we put these two vectors, Rs T2,
and we calculate that torque,
that torque is into
the board, which
is our positive direction,
and so that's plus T2 R2.
And now in our torque principle,
we set these two sides equal,
and we have minus T1 R plus
T2 R equals Icm alpha z.
Now, this is our
first equation, but it
requires some type of thought.
For the first thing, we
see that the tension T2
is equal to Icm over
R alpha z plus T1.
So the tensions on the
side are not equal.
Now, when we studied pulleys
earlier in the semester,
we imposed a condition that the
pulley was frictionless, which
meant that the rope was
sliding along the pulley,
and there was no
rotation in the pulley,
so there was no
contribution to alpha.
And in that case, T2
would be equal to T2.
We also could make a
slightly different statement.
We could say suppose
the mass of the pulley
was very, very small, an
extremely light pulley,
then Icm would be 0, and
again, T2 would be equal to T1.
So when we were dealing
with either massless pulleys
or ropes that were slipping
frictionlessly along a pulley,
the tension on both
sides was equal.
Now, something
different is happening.
We need to apply a greater
torque here than T1
because there is
rotational inertia.
We're causing the
pulley to accelerate.
So this torque from T2 has to be
bigger than the torque from T1,
and therefore T2
is bigger than T1,
so that is a very important way
to apply the torque principle.
When T2 is bigger than T1,
alpha will be positive,
and a positive
angular acceleration
is giving a rotation in which
our angle theta is not only
increasing, but its second
derivative is positive.
So that's crucial for beginning
the analysis of this problem.
The next step is to
analyze Newton's second law
on both objects, M1 and M2.
So I'll save our
result here, I'll
erase what we don't need, and
then continue the analysis.
So returning to our
analysis of a pulley
with two masses
and a string that's
not slipping around
the pulley, I now
want to begin analysis of
F equals Ma on object 1.
So as usual, I draw object 1.
I'll choose i hat 1 to
point in the direction
because I know it's
going to go that way
so my component of
acceleration will be positive.
In my force diagrams, I have a
normal force, I have gravity.
The string is pulling T1,
that's the same tension
at the end of the string.
The tension in the
string is not changing.
We're assuming it's
a massless string.
And I have a friction
force on object 1,
which is kinetic friction.
And now I can write
down Newton's second law
in the horizontal direction.
I could also call j hat 1
up, and my two equations
for Newton's second law
are T1 minus Fk is M1 A1,
and N1 minus M1 g is zero.
Now, I also know that
the kinetic friction, Fk,
is the coefficient of
friction mu times N1.
So my next equation for
F equals M A on object T1
is T1 minus mu N1 equals M1 A1.
Now I have to apply
the same analysis to 2.
Notice I'm not drawing my
force diagram on my sketch.
I do a separate
force diagram on 2.
So here's 2.
I have tension T2
and gravity M2g.
Now, even though I chose
a unit vector up here,
this choice of unit vectors is
completely independent of how
I choose unit vectors for 2.
Because object is
moving down, I would
prefer to choose j hat 2 down.
My acceleration for this
object will be positive.
And then when I apply
f equals MA object 2,
I get M2g minus T2 equals M2 A2.
So that's now my third equation,
that M2g minus T2 equals M2 A2.
And now I look at this.
System of equations.
And what are my unknowns?
T1, T2, alpha, A1, A2.
Five unknowns.
I'm treating properties of the
system, the radius mu, Icm,
actually the N1,
because it's in M1g,
I can simplify this
equation and replace this
with M1g, where
I'm already using
the other Newton's second law.
So I have three equations
and five unknowns.
I cannot solve this system.
But in all of these problems,
there's constraint conditions.
There's constraints between
how the masses are moving
and how the angular
acceleration pulley
is related to the linear
acceleration of the masses.
Let's consider mass 1 and 2.
They're attached by a string.
As mass 2 goes down,
mass 1 goes to the right.
The string is not
stretching, so they're
moving at the same rate, so
they have the same acceleration.
So my first constraint
is that A1 equals A2.
Now in general, I
have to be careful.
Plus or minus.
Why is it a plus sign and
not a minus sign here?
It's a plus sign because I've
chosen i hat to the right
and I've chosen j hat downwards.
If I'd chosen them differently,
that sign could have varied.
Now, let's focus
on the relationship
between the angular acceleration
of the pulley and M2.
Think about the strength.
Here we're on a
point on the rim.
This is a distance R, and
the pulley and the string
are moving together.
So there's a
tangential acceleration
of the pulley
equal to R alpha Z.
This is the tangential
acceleration of pulley
and string.
But the same string has a linear
acceleration, either A1 or A2.
So this has to be
equal to A2, this
is the linear acceleration
of the string.
And so that's our
last constraint, five,
that A1 equals R alpha.
And now I have a system of five
equations and five unknowns.
And the question is, how
can I find the acceleration?
So in general, when opposed
to a system like that,
I want to have some strategy.
Let's make a little space
to clear for our algebra.
OK, now, I look at this
system, and I say to myself,
which equation do I want
to use as a background?
My target is to find A1.
A1 is equal to A2.
Now, when I look at these
equations, T1 depends on A1,
T2 depends on A2,
which is equal to A1,
and alpha is also related to A1.
So I can use this
equation 1 as my backbone,
and substitute in T1, T2,
and alpha into that equation.
And now let's do that.
So when I solve
this equation for T1
equal to M1 A1 plus mu
M1g with the minus sign,
I get minus M1 A1 plus mu M1g
times R, that's my first piece.
I solve for T2, which
is M2g minus M2 A,
so I get M2g minus M2.
Now, A2 is equal to A1, so I
make my second substitution,
multiply it by R, and
that's equal to Icm.
And now I make my
final substitution,
that alpha z is
equal to A1 over R.
So if I now can collect
terms, minus, minus over here,
but there's an R
there, an R there, I'll
divide through by R, and
bring my A1 terms over
to the other side, and I'm
left with minus mu M1g plus M2g
equals Icm over R squared that
has the dimensions of mass,
because moment of inertia,
M R squared divided by R
squared, plus M1 A1 plus M2 A1.
And finally, as a
conclusion, I now
can solve for the
acceleration of my system
in terms of all of
these quantities.
And let's just put it all the
way down here at the bottom
that A1 equals M2g minus
mu M1g over Icm R squared
plus M1 plus M2.
Often, in types of problems
like these when there's
a lot of signers, you might end
up with a minus or a minus sign
down here, and if you looked
at that, that would imply that
with the right choice of
parameters, this could be zero
and that would be an
impossible solution.
So that's always a sign that
there could be something wrong.
The other thing we want to
check is, when does it actually
accelerate?
We have a condition.
So we can conclude
that if M2g is bigger
than Mu M1g then 2 will
start to go downwards.
If M2g were less than
M1g, then the problem
would be very different, because
two would not go downwards.
The friction would not be
kinetic, but would be static.
And that would vary, depending
on how much weight were here.
So if you went from 0 to
mu M1g, the static friction
would depend on how much
weight that's there.
So here is a full analysis of
rotational and translational
motion.
Takes a little bit of time
and a little bit of care,
but we've done it.